hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast SPR for aptima based molecular
interactions in programmable materials
I'm Brenda Kelly Kim and blab roots and
I'll be a moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by right foot
technologies life sciences weichert
develops and manufactures precision
analytical and diagnostic equipment in
Buffalo New York including surface
plasmon resonance spr instrument which
have become known for their robustness
flexibility ease of use and outstanding
sensitivity please visit www SPR com for
more information on right there SPR
instruments additionally write that
solution team is happy to adjust any
questions and discuss how we can help
you overcome your interaction analysis
challenges we looking important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit the questions
by typing them in the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking on the green he ran
a button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many of your questions as you can
today you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right in your slide window if you
have any technical problems fearing of
units presentation please click on a
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem for the green Q&A button lower
left would now like to introduce today's
speaker Aaron gaddis PhD candidate Penn
State University Department of file
engineering will now turn it over to
Erin for her presentation
hello thank you for the great
introduction I'm Erin gaddis I am a PhD
candidate at Penn State University
working in the wrong lab so our labs
focuses on using oligonucleotide xand
app tumors to create biomolecular and
biomimetic materials so we use surface
plasmon resonance and evaluating a lot
of the binding affinities and the
interactions that are so pivotal for
these materials so this talk is going to
focus on how we use SPR but also will
have a more broad reach into how SPR
functions and some other samples and
techniques that can be used for spr so
first I'm going to introduce what
surface plasmon resonance or SPR is and
how it worked I'm also going to be
looking at the samples and detection
strategies that are available and then
talk a little bit about that at analysis
and how this can be done in the output
for an spr next I'm going to be talking
a bit about how our lab uses surface
plasmon resonance to evaluate
biomolecular interactions specifically
using oligonucleotides so we do this
using oligonucleotide for cell capture
and release for the loading and release
of growth factors and also for signal
amplification so surface plasmon
resonance is a technique that is able to
evaluate the molecular interactions
between two molecules in real time and
also in a label-free environment and the
surface plasmon resonance system really
functions with three main components the
first being the sensor chip which
contains the immobilized lagging of
interest next is the microfluidic system
which delivers the analyte to the sensor
chip and then the third and probably
most complex part is the optical
measurement system which allows the
changes in local refractive indices that
are sent to indicate the changes in mass
of the surface ship interface
so you can see in the image on the upper
right our labs surface plasmon resonance
system that has a dual channel so a
sample and reference channel and the
image on the lower right shows kind of
the sensor gram schematic for what we're
looking at for spr where we have a
ligand immobilized to the sensor chip we
have an analyte that's able to bind to
this ligand eventually most of the
reaction sites on the ligand chip are
filled and then we have some
dissociation of the analyte from the
ligand so first I'm going to talk a bit
about the optical detection system this
is probably the most important part for
understanding how surface plasmon
resonance works so the optical detection
system functions based on the use of a
prism and censorship above this prism
the sensor chip is coated with a thin
gold film and the prism has a refractive
index that is higher than that of the
environment at the surface interface of
the chip so this is something like a
physiological buffer so under these
conditions when light enters the prison
above the critical angle it can be
totally internally reflect reflected and
this reflection and the photons that are
involved in this produce an evanescent
wave at the interface that decays as it
goes away from the interface about 300
nanometers is as far as it extends so
when mobile electrons in this thin gold
layer at the interface are moving we can
think of that more like a plasma surface
since their mobile and surface plasmons
from the density fluctuations of this
interface can propagate along the
surface so when we have light that has
the momentum of photons matching that of
the surface plasmons we can say that
resonance occurs and this is based on
some parameters such as the angle of
light the wavelength of the light and
also the refractive indices of them
terials the prism and the solution so
when the photons from the light are
exciting the plasmas we can note that
there is a reduction in detected light
since these photons are no longer being
reflected and detected and this
reduction occurs at a specific angle the
minimum of this reduction is at a
specific angle which we can call the
resonance angle so when we're scanning a
a range of angles of light we can look
at the reflectivity and see that a
minimum exists and this is our resonance
angle as you can see in the figure on
left so when the output reaches this we
have the minimum and we can see that
this shifts as we have mass that's
absorbed on our censorship so changes in
the interface are going to change the
local refractive index and this is
what's altering the resonance angle so
now that we have looked at the optical
detection system we can focus on the
sensor chip so the sensor chip is I've
explained earlier consists of a fen
middle layer that is on top of a glass
chip and this allows for the ligands be
immobilized and this is the Ligon that
you're looking at interactions with so
some immobilization strategies are
listed in this slide the most common
being a mean coupling using EDC NHS
chemistry this forms a covalent bond
some other strategies are using a
streptavidin or new travatan on the chip
and a biotinylated ligon and also gold
file can be used to create
self-assembled monolayers so there are a
variety of immobilization strategies and
this is important to know because when
we're doing a mobilization it may be
more advantageous depending on your
ligands to use a different one of these
strategies and also we can think about
the amount of binding sites we have on
our chip so many chips use a polymer
matrix to increase the amount of binding
site at the chip so we can look
the balance between binding sites and
signal strength in the image in the
center of this slide we can see that as
the evanescent wave moves from the
interface we can see it decays so at 300
nanometers there's a very low signal
strength whereas at the interface
there's a much higher signal strength so
abiding interactions that occur further
from the surface actually we'll have a
have less of a signal that's being
detected than those that are near the
interface so this binding balance
between the binding sites and signal
strength is usually around 100
nanometers which is the polymer length
from the surface generally we can also
look at the figure on the Left which
shows a sensor gram for an amine
coupling reaction for the immobilization
of the ligand or several items in this
case we can see an a first we have a
baseline sensor signal which it be
increases as we use EDC NHS to activate
the surface at sea we see that the
baseline is maintained after we are
washing the surface with our running
buffer and then in D we incubate this
surface with the ligand of interest or
in this case several ligands we can see
the mass increasing and then an e we do
a wash step to remove the binding of
loose loose plugins in F the group in
the scientific rewards paper here uses a
deactivation step which deactivates the
surface but also is used to remove
loosely bound ligands and then g you can
see that the final signal is higher than
that in a which would show that the
ligands have been immobilized on the
surface so when we're looking at a flow
cell like that on the bottom right we
can see that it's at the top of our
sensor chip it has two channels the
first being the immobilization channel
or sample channel where the Ligon is
immobilized in the second channel we
have a reference
channel where there's no likened and
this allows the microfluidic system to
be able to deliver analyte to both
channels in equal conditions with the
exception of one having a ligand and one
having no lightened and the service of
control that can be subtracted from the
sample channel later for data analysis
so after we have found our analytes of
interest in a lot of their dissociation
we generate binding curves and now we
need to analyze them so in Reichert's
software the analysis is done using
trace drawer which is shown in the
screenshot on the top image and this
allows for the alignment of start time
in response to zero blank subtractions
and subtracts functions of reference
Channel and then the fitting of the
curves that are generated to models such
as one to one binding two to one or one
to two binding and then allowing for
some considerations like mass transport
depletion which is shown in the lower
image and this occurs when the bulk
concentration has a higher concentration
of analyte than that in the what we call
a depletion zone or layer right at the
interface and this has a slower
Association rate that would be expected
based on the concentration in the bulk
in an assemble way during dissociation
there can become a retention layer or
zone near the interface where the
concentration of analyte is higher than
that of the bulk so that molecules will
dissociate but then rebind to another
site and this slows the dissociation
rate so these considerations can be made
when analyzing data so other than
binding kinetics like that shown in the
image on the top we can do other types
of analysis using surface plasmon
resonance this includes equilibrium
analysis like the lower image where the
concentration is plotted against the
maximum response we can also look at the
festa facility of molecules finding with
immobilized most
and we can look at many different types
of molecular interactions such as the
interactions between proteins and small
molecules cells artificial membranes and
oligonucleotides so our lab specifically
looks at oligonucleotide interactions
either with other oligonucleotides or in
some cases proteins so our lab also
focuses on the use of oligonucleotide
app tumors and I'll give a little bit of
background on what app tomers are so
nucleic acid app demers their short
single-stranded and oligonucleotides
that can be selected for randomized
libraries using the flux process so the
flux process is shown on the right in
this process the randomized library is
incubated with the target of interest
and this can be a cell or it can be a
protein and the nice thing about this
process is if you have a cell of
interest you don't have to know the
specific surface receptors you're
looking at you can select toward this
cell and then later determine what the
target on the cell actually was after
selecting against the target of interest
this population that binds is later
allowed to interact with a control
target or a negative target and those
the sequences that do not bind the
negative target are then selected
amplified and brought through another
round so as the selects process occurs
round after round the population of
interest and with high binding
specificity to the target of interest is
enriched and this is how Optimas are
developed so some of the benefits of
using app tumors especially when we're
comparing after MERS with other
molecules like antibodies if that app
tumors are very small they're usually
less than 50 like only 50 nucleotides in
length so we are very simple to
synthesize using chemical methods with
little batch to batch variation which is
helpful when conducting experiments for
this process and then when we're looking
at after
as we see very little immunogenicity so
this is good for biomolecular
interactions we don't have these types
of concerns for biocompatibility after
MERS are also small so that they can be
more easily delivered intracellularly
are our group use this surface plasmon
resonance in many ways but also others
are very interested in using surface
plasmon resonance to look at
oligonucleotide interactions with other
biomolecules so some of these
applications are listed here biosensors
is a great application for surface
plasmon resonance and oligonucleotides
so in the central figure by Chen Adele
we can see that a vgf Optima is
immobilized on the surface of the
surface plasmon resonance censorship and
then vegf is able to be bound to this in
the next step a another app tumor for
vegf it finds a different site is
allowed to incubate and this app tumor
contains multiple primers that can be
extended to increase the mass on the
surface and detect very small quantities
of the EGF we can also see that surface
plasmon resonance can be used to
evaluate the affinity of after MERS for
their targets so in the figure on the
right we can see two apt immers that are
specific for thrombin which is shown in
the center these antithrombin aptamers
find two different locations on thrombin
one being the fibrinogen binding site
and the second being the heparin binding
site in this or in this study by
hasegawa i'll we can see that they use a
linker to link these two different
antibodies and they evaluate the binding
affinity of this optoma dimer fourth
robin after more Phineas Minh study for
many different Optimas some of which
I've lifted listed below next we can see
the optimist can be used to verify the
specificity of the sequence and also to
look at some of the ways that sequences
interact with each other such as the
formation of DNA polymers or the
displacement of oligonucleotides but
other on polygamy
Cleo tides so at this point I'm going to
move on to some of the work that our
group is done we look at the specificity
of some sequences using SPR in this
figure so you can see in the cartoon on
the Left we have a sequence a that's
immobilized on our surface plus are on
our chip and we usually use new Travie
de and by its interactions in this case
so the biotinylated sequence is
immobilized and then we incubate this
chip with sequence B which finds to
sequence a with 20 base pairs and when
we look at the sensor gram on the right
we can see the sequence B is able to
bind in situations when the sequence has
not been altered but when the sequence
has been scrambled or the order of the
nucleotides has been randomized we can
see the blue signal showing that very
little binding is occurring so the
sequence specificity is very important
in this case next we can use sequence
see which binds to sequence be with 25
base pairs to dissociate sequence be
from a and this you can see in the
sensor gram in the red signal where the
sequence has 25 base pairs if we lower
the amount of base pair against these
only 20 base pairs we can see that this
displacement does not occur in a similar
way we scramble the sequence of see it
doesn't specifically bind be in this
case and in the same way we don't see
any association of be from a so we're
going to look at an application for this
system using these sequences to release
captured tumor cells from a surface so
in the schematic on the Left we can see
that a sequence the primary
complementary sequence in purple is
attached to a hydrogel surface and an
Optima is able to hybridize with this
sequence much like sequence a and
sequence B were able to hybridize in the
previous flood these optimizer on am a
tumor cell line which is shown
being captured on this surface and the
images on the right we can capture these
cells and then quantify the amount of
cells bound for area next we can use a
secondary sequence which binds to the
apt Amir sequence with more of these
earth than the abdomen sequence binds to
the primary sequence and this displaces
not only the apt or sequence but also
any cells that are attached to this app
t'mer and when we look at the images
back on the right we can see that when
the complementary sequence is 25 base
pairs with the app t'mer most cells are
released when the sequence is scrambled
on the rightmost image we can see that
very little cells are released so this
is a very specific release system and
this sequence are in this system we can
see that the surface can be regenerated
for multiple rounds of cell captioner
release and this is important when we
look at house humor cells are able to be
captured and then evaluated so tumor
cells are often very rare and difficult
to isolate so once they are captured
it's important to be able to remove them
in a non-destructive way and then
analyze the surface markers that may be
used to create more effective drugs or
targeting strategies in the future we
can also use surface plasmon resonance
to evaluate the binding affinity of
abers versus their length so in the
image on the left we can see the sensor
gram showing that different lengths of
apt immers have different binding
affinities and that we can use yet again
a triggering sequence on the right to
release these optimus from their target
so we can apply this to a PDGF BB
release system so this is an optima that
is able to bind to this protein we can
create three different versions of this
app summer the high-affinity after the
moderate affinity Optima which is the
same as the high-affinity except for two
nucleotides that have been altered and
then the low affinity after which is
much more different from the high
affinity after and we can see that each
app de mer
a specific secondary structure based on
the sequence and that just the changing
the two nucleotides from the high to the
moderate affinity Optimus vastly alters
the secondary structure and this is
going to affect how the Optima is able
to find to its target so i can use spr
to evaluate the binding of this after
mer with its target at different
concentrations and when we look in the
graph on the right this sensor gram
shows that the binding affinity of the
high is much more than the moderate and
low after murs at the same concentration
so when we apply this to a system we can
use this app t'mer to load and then also
release PDGF BB from a biomaterial which
in this case is a hydrogel so this
hydrogel is porous and can be loaded
with the the protein of interest in this
case the Optima is already conjugated
within the hydrogel matrix so it's
chemically conjugated not physically
conjugated and then we can load this
protein of interest and it forms a
complex with the Optima so it's finding
specifically and we can see in the graph
from the lower left that the highest
affinity Optima is able to load the most
amount of PDGF BB next we can use a
complementary sequence which hybridizes
with our conjugated after our sequence
to free the target protein and this is a
sequence-specific and in dosage specific
release so we can see that when one x
amount of our complimentary sequence is
added the release is only half of that
of a 2x postage and this can be done at
multiple periods of time to release the
PDGF BB on demand
we can also use SPR to evaluate the
formation of DNA polymers from the
surface of a chip so in this case we'll
have a linear DNA initiator structure or
di which is immobilized on the sensor
chip which is not shown in the sensor
gram on the right next we intubate to
DNA monomers dm1 and DM to DM one is
able to bind the initiator and change
the confirmation from a hairpin
structure as shown on left to a linear
structure in this case the linear
structure serves as an initiator for the
hairpin structure of DM to to open to a
linear structure which initiates dm1 so
this will alternate sequentially to form
a DNA polymer in the sensor gram on the
right we can see that when the initiator
is immobilized on the chip and we pass
DM to over the chip this monomer cannot
interact with the initiator to linearize
and therefore very little binding is
observed when DM one however is
incubated with this initiator
functionalized chip we can see an
increase in mass which would indicate
that the monomer one has down to the
surface when both monomers are incubated
in solution we can see a much greater
increase in mass which would suggest
that the polymerization is occurring at
the surface so this system can be used
as a signal amplification strategy in
this instance we use nanoparticles that
have an attached DNA initiator as a
activation point for the polymerization
to occur so in the left image the
schematic one shows that when there's no
initiator the polymerization cannot
occur on the particle in the sequence
number two or the in number two we can
see that the initiator can be bound by
monomer one but we can't see a large
increase in fluorescence in into for the
fluorescence image at the lower area
however in three we can see that when
monomers which have a fluorophore
conjugated to them are able to be
incubated with the initiator
functionalized particle a large amount
of fluorescence intensity can be
observed so this shows that the use of
the polymers with the floor for attached
to each monomer can create a larger
fluorescent signal than one floor for
pre-action site and this can be observed
when we're looking at labeling
biomolecules so in this case collagen is
being labeled and on the right we can
see that when each monomer is labeled by
a different floor for we can see that
they can be colocalized which would show
that not only are the monomers binding
to the to the particle but also they're
in the same location and would indicate
the formation of DNA polymers of these
locations we can also functionalize our
DNA polymers with apt immerse to create
polyvalent Optimas and increase the
amount of affinity ligands that can be
conjugated for reaction site so in this
case we have an initiator which similar
to the last study we can using as a
starting point to foreign DNA pollard's
which can be our polymeric scaffold in
this case though we have a binding
region that's on a ma number one which
we can call the toehold region and this
extends and allows the binding and
hybridization of the AB de mer so when
the Optima is incubated with this
polymeric scaffold binding between the
Optima in this toehold region creates a
polyvalent after restructure so when we
look at the sensor gram on the right we
can see that the DNA polymers can be
formed through the use of both monomers
and that by having this binding region
in the case of the yellow versus the
green line we can see that the abdomen
can be bound when there's this toehold
region where the Optima cannot be bound
in the case of a mono one with no
toehold region when we have a polymer
scaffold we can see in the inset that
the Optima injection results in a larger
increase in mass which would show that
polymeric and polyvalent after MERS have
been formed and if the color is
relatively quickly less than two minutes
so we can use this polyvalent optima
system to increase the logins display
for the capture of circulating tumor
cells so in this case the abdomen is
specific for a surface receptor on a
circulating tumor cell line and we can
compare the surface reaction sites with
one optima per reaction site which we
call direct conjugation to multiple
optimus / reaction site in our polymeric
display and this is done on a hydrogel
surface so we can see that as the cells
are incubated for longer amount of time
the amount of captured cells increases
in both cases however the polyvalent
display affords a larger amount of
captured cells at each time point and
this is a significant amount of cell
capture so this is important for areas
that have very difficult surfaces to
functionalize or where there's limited
surface reaction sites available we can
also release our DNA polymers from the
surface using a complementary sequence
similar to some of the complimentary
sequence releases we've seen earlier so
in this case we create DNA polymers on
the surface and then incubate these
polymeric scaffolds with afterwards to
create polyvalent after murs and we can
see in the sensor gram on the left and
when the complementary sequence that
specific for this polymer has been
incubated with the polyvalent optimus a
large decrease in massive is found to
occur however when this complementary
sequence is scrambled we can see that
the mass does not significantly decrease
so we can see into the complementary
sequence is specific for this system
when we look at the figure on the right
we can see that when our appt tumors are
labeled with the floor for our DNA
polymers can be shown as a fluorescent
image and that cell can be captured when
we add a scrambled complementary
sequence we see very little decrease in
fluorescence intensity and most cells
remain bound to our hydrogel however
when we use our complementary sequence
in its functional form we can see that
the fluorescence intensity of the
hydrogel decreases significantly
and then this would indicate the DNA
polymers have been dissociated from the
surface when we look at the amount of
cells bound in this instance we can see
that many have been dissociated as well
and this is important to note that this
is not from the complementary sequence
interacting directly with the cells but
instead by dissociating the DNA polymers
so as a summary today we've talked a bit
about how spr can be used to detect
molecular interactions in real time and
with no necessary labeling steps we've
also looked at the types of samples that
can be used including proteins nucleic
acids and other small molecules and how
after MERS can be used to test the
binding of targets with tunable affinity
we've also talked a bit about how our
lab group uses SPR to evaluate the
optima specificity the ability to
release after murs and how DNA
hybridization can be used to form
polyvalent optimism DNA polymers if
you're more interested in learning a bit
about surface plasmon resonance and the
fundamentals about this process these
are some resources i recommend the first
two bullets additionally if you have any
if you see the use of SPR in your future
I would recommend looking at reichert
technology which is the system that we
use also for the analysis software I
would recommend looking at trace draw
which is associated with right good
software and also with scrubber which is
another data analysis software I'd like
to thank my advisor dr. young long and
all my lab mates in the long lab
especially mark you tell and shuey whose
research has been featured heavily in
this presentation I'd also like to thank
the hosts Riker technologies for giving
me this great opportunity and all the
funding sources that allow this research
to be conducted so at this point I'd be
happy to take any questions you may have
thank you
thank you and for that informative
presentation before we get started on
our question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit your questions
by typing them with Q&A button which can
be found by clicking on the green a
button the lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
as many of your questions as a pen we'd
also like to let our audience know how
to plan their continuing education
certificate please click on a CD button
at the bottom left which will take you
to a acc accent page to log in and kind
of your certificate our first question
is how do you deke envelope the specific
interaction of an Optima to its target
from the nonspecific one this is a nice
question it's important for
opportunities to be specific for their
target and that's why the selects
process has a very rigorous amount of
cycles and negative target selection
steps and this allows the target to be
selected only for those molecules that
you're wanting to bind and this can be
tested later using SPR for control
molecules as well but a lot of the
specificity is determined using the
selects process and from there a range
of app tomers can be determined and
tested for further binding specificity
we thank you our next question how do
you screen off the negative charges from
an optimist phosphate backbone and
causing nonspecific charged interactions
so the buffer that is used when working
with Optimus is very important to defuse
some of the repulsive negative charges
and this is what's allowing the DNA
specifically for something like a
hybridization to occur otherwise DNA
sequences may not be able to hybridize
and for many secondary structures or
polymers so buffer is very important in
this regard thank you our next question
have you investigated the different
effects of patients particularly violent
ones to aptima binding so diabaly
occasions are they're important and are
especially associated with a lot of
aggregation and binding and this work
has been done by a lot of groups
especially when looking at buffers and
the importance of these cations in the
binding of afterwards to other
biomolecules but our group does not
specialized so much in the selects
process in regards to this and more so
in the testing of after MERS to create
biomaterials functional biomaterials
thank you our next question in your
experience you've got a lot of
background binding with strep dividing
biotin systems
so we often we often work with biotin
streptavidin interactions for spr and we
find that usually we don't have a lot of
nonspecific binding in this instance the
biotin stripped avidin or new travatan
bond is very strong so that's an
advantage when we're mobilizing our
ligands and we don't find that we have a
lot of extra binding to the surface in
this instance thank you well so many
questions our next question how do you
distinguish the binding of an apt amount
that it's based on structure or sequence
so the apt or specificity comes from its
sequence and that's what allows it to
form these secondary structures that
allow it to interact specifically with
its target so finding these sequences is
very important and after using this luxe
process we can sequence the sequences
that have been found to bind the most
specifically toward our apt or toward
our target and in this case we can
discover a bit more about the binding
interactions between our appt tours and
our specific targets and maybe even the
identity of these targets thank you our
next question is sequence ABC and
optimum
so in our interactions shown by
sequences a B and C we have sequence a
which is not an Optima but just a
binding site for sequence B which is an
app t'mer a sequence B is what is
interacting with our target biomolecules
in this case oftentimes the cell or a
protein and then sequence c is not an
Optima but binds to the optimum with
more base pairs than between DNA and
this allows the dissociation of our apt
or from a and allows a to be remaining
on the surface so they can be used for
another round of capture and release
right our next question to normally can
mobilize your aptima target to the SPR
chip if so do you use any coupling as
the conjugation technique so when we're
evaluating Optimus binding the proteins
we often use a mean coupling and we find
that this is a pretty useful way of
immobilizing the proteins to the surface
and usually this the system has worked
out very well for our analysis right our
next question how do you control the
release of growth factors from the
hydrogel from time those
so the recent release of growth factors
can be can be controlled in kind of two
different ways the first being the
amount or concentration of a
complementary release sequence which can
determine the amount of protein that is
released from the Optima that's loading
this protein in the other instance we
can use different optima affinities and
this can regulate the amount of growth
factor that's bound and potentially the
amount and strongness of binding between
these two so that some maybe it
associated but this is a less controlled
way of doing this great yeah Bob one
more question did you mention the
software for analysis again so the
analysis software that we use we use
trace draw but also we use this rubber
and the data from the Ryker system that
we get from the binding of our analyte
to our logging can be exported either
both work very well
great thank you that is all the time
that we have for questions now I just
like to turn it back to Erin to see if
she has any final comments or advice for
our audience I guess I would just like
to say that SPR has been a great
technique that our lab has used in many
different types of studies and we've
gained a lot of quantitative information
about the interactions between our
oligonucleotide systems and their target
molecules but if this is the type of
interaction you'd like to investigate
even if it's not with after MERS I would
highly recommend looking into using
surface plasmon resonance to get a bit
more of the binding interaction data in
your system's I think it's a very
worthwhile technique to attempt for any
biomolecule interactions thank you again
and I would also like to thank today's
sponsor right web technologies life
sciences for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
March 2016 will be receiving an email
from lab roots alerting you as to when
that webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
email to your colleagues in any
happiness today's live event once again
thank you to Erin into our sponsor right
for life technologies thank you very
much